resigned so yeah
um you know I think manager of needs to
survive this first game even a draw is a
great result for manager in this first
one just get the black game out of the
way survive and move on to the next one
okay yeah so this first game is actually
super important mom Jr needs to feel at
least inspired after it yeah we'll set
the whole mood of the whole tournament
uh sorry the whole match because uh if
he loses he's also must not lose
situation and uh well you know it's very
difficult to play chess when your back
is right up against the wall and we see
Shaq getting ready he's a very cool
customer
right yeah I mean but I really love his
style I love the fire that he brings to
the board and we see yanchisoft develop
his King's night and now push the
Queen's Pawn forward yeah so by
transposition it started as a ready it's
now gone into the Queen's Gambit and
it's the Queen's Gambit accepted meaning
the black did temporarily go Pawn up but
uh that Gambit has now that gamuted pawn
has now been recovered and still a very
typical type of position this is
Mainline theory if you study if you've
ever looked at the Queen's Camp accepted
you will have seen this position
Alex whole idea is to push pawns on this
left side White's Bishop has been kicked
back and blacks light Square Bishop
normally the problem piece is now quite
a good one and there's been a lot of
debate about this position in recent
times Sri Lanka yeah definitely I mean I
can see many games on the database and
I'm just going to have a look at which
one is the most popular move it's
actually popular for why it's just to
develop the Queen's Knight just to put
it in front of the queen and just
continue development I have to say one
thing about this position
it's actually very difficult for black
to win this it's a very solid choice for
Mama jarov yeah and uh as we mentioned
solid maybe is not the worst thing in
the first game at least with black to
survive is the goal
so my major has clearly prepared this do
you want to hear the stats though okay
42 victory for white 40 victory for
black and 18 Victory sorry 40 victory
has a draw what am I saying 40 is just
draw 18 percent
for black for black wow okay so white
has a very good score yeah very good
score and uh okay what did he choose
okay he picked up his a pawn and
challenged Black's pawns there on the
left and uh this one doesn't have as
good a win rate
for white only 34 okay and uh 25 for
black
okay so reasons to be optimistic for my
major of maybe the first small surprise
of the game white pushing the spawn but
it's quite logical it is quite typical
in these ideas black had some strong
pawns over there on the left side so you
loosen them up and now White Knight is
running forward and it's got a nice
Outpost white tonight is heading towards
C4 where it can no longer be challenged
and first I expect Judah to maybe bring
his Rook into the game that rook in the
corner there we go
activating all the pieces there's no
calculation to be done nothing really to
work out in this position just general
principles improve your worst place
piece White's Queen maybe could be uh
improved in the next three or four moves
White's other Rook needs to get into the
game somehow
first maybe that white knight is coming
forward yep I agree
I think a knight will definitely come
forward I wonder whether
I mean yesterday we saw the night come
into the center quite often do you think
it will happen again yeah we saw that in
both games from Judo right uh both games
Duda landed with a knight on E5 on this
Square in the middle of the board
and it was powerful both times
um he had quite a consistent uh run of
luck with that idea and will he play it
again I'm more expecting the other
Knight to move first yep there we go so
this is the C4 square that we mentioned
earlier
can never really be challenged by a pawn
the only way you can ever trade off this
piece is with your own Knight so we
might see that one for black later but
first
I'm sure if you can't delay it too much
longer he needs to Castle his King
and uh once he does let's assume he does
it now after a little bit of thinking
then it will be time for Duda to decide
how do you get this rook in the game
maybe you lift your queen up somewhere
uh maybe you move the queen you shift
The Rook across at some point uh I
wouldn't be surprised if he goes back to
his tried and trusted uh trusted method
of dropping the other Knight into the
center for example now black probably
okay it does happen uh probably doesn't
want to take I was going to say because
White's Pawn could capture and suddenly
this attack in the night and white has a
launch pad on the D6 Square supported by
White's Pawn
pretty nice for white so black doesn't
really want to release the tension yet
very well known and actually the most
popular move by long shot is to capture
the pawn in the middle yeah
yeah so first you take a pawn and only
when the and it has happened only when
white recaptures with the bishop or with
the queen then maybe you trade off a set
of knights and things are getting
hoovered off the board
it's it's just about whether long term
uh Pawn structure for example on the
left side of the board whether this is a
bit loose for black these two pawns are
potentially weak for example this white
Bishop kind of long term wants to eye up
this Pawn for black meanwhile the big
advantage in this type of position is
that the Knight sometimes has access to
this Square because you have pushed your
Pawn forward quite fast so it's just
small strategic things here
it's a it's a very cagey battle and I'm
surprised dude is thinking because yeah
again this is quite a typical type of
position you can predict this pretty
much if your opponent plays this opening
but okay both players have been very
quick up to this point yeah definitely I
was just going to ask do you think um
Judo is surprised by Shaq's opening
choice that he's chosen such a solid
variation or was he was he expecting
something a bit more Cutthroat yeah
that's a good question
um I guess Shaq hinted yesterday in one
of the games that he was going down the
Queen's gonna be accepted if you
remember the ready opening yesterday he
took a Pawn on C4 very quickly so he's
he's kind of hinting that he was
preparing this opening but yeah for the
match situation for the match itself
it's
it's a questionable Choice uh I guess
Sharky just wants to survive this one
and then maybe game three when he has
his next Black then he'll know whether
he needs to win or needs to take more
risks and then he'll choose a different
one
is opening his black opening from game
four yesterday was a bit of a disaster
in the end so
um this one more solid
we um are obviously aware of the Chess
World talking about Hans niemann's
recent lawsuit and I just wanted to say
one thing about it so since play Magnus
group is included in the complaint we
will not talk about this at the current
time and today in the studio we'll only
focus on the big Final in AIM chess
rapid and what do you think right now
David will this game end up with a
winner or a draw
I it's hard to say uh early days I'm
gonna say there's gonna it's gonna be
decisive just because it's these two
players it's they're both really
ambitious
um I'm gonna pick white slightly because
I've looked at these types of positions
before and black has to be quite careful
black has to be accurate in order to
fully equalize at the moment black is
still fighting for that equality how
about you Ivanka uh try any predictions
you think
in the middle fifty percent
yeah exactly and uh well
we do have a competition where we're
asking us to show asking you guys to
show us your best chess meme for a
chance to win a mug with David's mug on
it
and tapes new bay and says that uh they
have they have showed us a meme and says
that that's literally me don't know if
this is the best here we go you can see
players top players when they are down a
pawn
me when I'm down
hang on I'll read it me who is the queen
of a ricktown yay
I like it yeah and there we see the
knights leave the board
um getting one step closer to the
tension going and Dennis M Forster also
shared with us Amin
see if we can bring it up
we see a confident Eric icy there yeah
this one's a classic a moment of tension
in the Vatican if the bishop moves
forward the queen can take him
that one was doing the rounds last year
it was such a good one yeah so keep them
coming remember you can tweet us your
memes using the hashtag chess Champs
funny I like that picture with the queen
yeah and meanwhile about nitrate
has happened due to takes back with a
bishop
I vaguely remember this is maybe six
months ago I was looking at this
position from the white side and I
remember thinking that the White Queen
taking that pawn was the acid test of
Black's opening but taking back with a
bishop also looks very healthy
white Bishop Now controls a lot of
squares it needs to be traded off at
some point managerv needs to neutralize
the strength of White's Knight and
White's Bishop next to it those two
pieces in the center of the board do
control do dominate
proceedings at the moment but it is
Black's move so he has a bit of time no
direct threats on the board
it feels like he's impatient to kind of
make his comeback he's just playing so
quickly with 16 and only now is he
ticking under 15 minutes
great preparation but also just
confident I guess yeah definitely
confident and now he's taking a pause uh
there's still a little bit baffling
actually because we're still in the
Realms of theory his position has been
playing many times
um most of the moves that black players
are simply improving moves so the Knight
will jump forward to C5 a black pawn
will come and protect the B4 Pawn Yeah
and finally another one is actually to
centralize the light squared Bishop so
these moves don't have any specific plan
they're just simply improving maximizing
the potential of the black pieces yeah
this one looks nice and healthy later
you can hint I don't think you want a
rush but you can hint that you might
take this Knight at some point because
this is a very strong piece as we
mentioned I like this one as well just
fixing your pawns kind of defending them
as a pair here they defend each other
the only downside is to the black queen
has to stay kind of defending this Pawn
because White's Knight is also attacking
it at some point and the other move also
maybe the most natural move I guess uh
bring the Black Knight forward normally
they say nights before Bishops so the
knights lead from the front Okay he
chooses the other method you mentioned
there Ivanka bringing the bishop to the
center we could see for example if white
plays a quiet move uh black go for
symmetry so here we see Black's night
spring forward and these four pieces
they uh they're just all equally strong
and they can trade off for each other
but that would only lead towards a draw
so yeah in the current position it looks
like Mama Jarvis found a nice way with
his Bishop in the center of the board
to lock things up yeah
and again this has been played before
not it's not I have to say this bishop
centralizing itself wasn't the most
popular move just primarily because it's
not the most natural and here white has
played two options one of them is very
intriguing actually it's actually to
step forward with the a pawn and just
fix blacksa air porn on A6 and make it a
permanent liability
and this looks like a pawn sacrifice
initially but I don't think it is after
Bishop takes Knight we would see an
exchange Black's Queen can now suddenly
swoop out and capture this Pawn it's no
longer defended but at the end we would
see actually there's a couple of tactics
here for example White's Rook if it
wants to if you want to keep things
simple could just swing across hitting
the black queen but also picking up the
black pawn behind it once the queen
moves and there are also tricks in this
position for example but you're looking
at loose pieces this Knight is
undefended you could consider maybe
jumping out the way with the white
Bishop going to capture a pawn and when
black recaptures with the king queen
takes Knight and that was a loose piece
you've regained your pawners white and
Black's King is out in the open
so yeah I really like this movie of
anchor that you pointed out just pushing
this Pawn forward and if black doesn't
go for that kind of uh that continuation
that we just showed then this Pawn
clamps down it supports maybe an
invasion on this Square so for example
the White Knight or white Bishop could
use the square
that's a Duda type of mission it is a
dude we actually saw Duda do that
I was suddenly just uh taken aback by my
Duda dudette
it was a bit of a mouthful uh yeah
yeah yeah Paul she played something very
similar yesterday yeah will he do it
again yeah I think so and uh maybe this
could be that small inaccuracy though
I'm talking about maybe he should have
uh Mama Jarvis should have taken the
time out to prevent uh White from
advancing this a pawn
and yeah that's perhaps why the bar is
slightly in White's favor so would that
be the most ambitious move by deeper
right now definitely okay definitely
um maybe some small risk involved if you
push your Pawn into Black's half of the
board because it becomes more vulnerable
than it is right now White's pawns on
the left side they protect each other
they're very safe but if you want to be
ambitious fix your opponent's weaknesses
stop your opponent's pawns from
connecting with each other then yeah you
play that move
and only then do you start to maybe
formulate a longer term plan
due to spending three minutes now
it's hard to see what else for white to
be honest
um White's Queen could step up I guess
just to bring the other white Rook the
white Rook next to the sorry this side
and next to the white king that needs to
be improved but that would be very slow
yeah push that pawn I think uh at least
that would ask questions of mamajarov oh
it doesn't yeah
and I wasn't expecting this one and I
could think the database is going to
tell me it's a novelty no one has played
this queen move that actually stepped up
the queen one square forward uh here
she's she's at her maximum potential but
I think perhaps uh Shakura should take
the opportunity and pop his apron
prevent white from clamping down a lot
of sense uh also this white Queen's
slightly vulnerable the Black Knight
could go and attack her so yeah I'm also
slightly baffled by this choice of
square by Duda
like some logic behind it White's other
Rook now on the f file wants to swing
across behind that White Queen
so um yeah there is a plan
but not the most natural from Duda and
La Majora has now paused often if your
opponent plays an unnatural move right
it's just human instinct to be like
what's that and uh try to reformulate
your plants
yeah I agree I mean you always do that I
mean even if your opponent plays the
most terrible move I mean you're most
people's reaction is always just to take
a step back and go hang on a second I
thought this was not possible because of
this and then you know once you gather
your thoughts you gather emotions then
you play your move she's very good
advice always to pause
even if the move you're going to play is
very obvious because then you just have
a quick scan you look at the
Alternatives and you know they have this
old
uh Maxim which is like when you see a
good move stop and look for a better one
okay and that's yeah
it's very basic but it's very much worth
your while yeah I call it a blunder
check just just in case you're
accidentally putting a piece on a bad
square or dropping a piece on the other
side of the board just scan yeah 10
second scan okay my pieces are safe they
won't fall off the board and then you
can move so how does that work in
practice so to do that 10 second scan
you the move you want to make you make
it in your head and just double check
that okay with this piece here
my king isn't in danger my pieces can't
be taken is that the scan you make
essentially yeah I mean there are
different levels you can go to uh often
I'm just like okay did my opponent have
a threat no I don't think he did and
then I can play my plan
um okay the opponent has a threat now on
the board Mama jarov attacking the White
Queen with Black Knight
dude has two options he's either got a
retreat that White Queen
off to the left somewhere just step her
back a square or two or dude I can
remove this knight from the board he can
capture this Knight normally you don't
want to part with your Bishops Bishops
are fantastic pieces because the center
of the board is quite open it's not
locked down with pawns
and uh White's dark Square Bishop in the
center looks fantastic so I I'd be
reluctant to trade it off but
don't Trade It Off
made me I would never ever trade off
that beautiful dark Square Bishop for
that night yeah it's not worth it I
agree I would be very reluctant but dude
is pausing which makes me think
he's gonna do it normally when dudas
stop
Retreat the queen you know move her away
I mean I mean lots of people will be
asking us you know but why did Duda put
the queen on such a weird Square you
know on the first row
yeah and that would be a good question
um the thing is Queens just like Bishops
they are long range pieces so actually
they do a good job supporting the Army
from behind they're like those archers
uh in war you don't want to use your
archers at the front because you need to
give them range you need to keep them
safe as well and they can hit their
targets from any distance
and uh Queens actually completely fine
you just need to keep them safe for the
for the end game
um you only want to put Queens in the
middle of the board when there's
virtually no pieces left so white screen
just Tucker away
you often see this Queen's just staying
at the back with their Rooks it's
Knights and Bishops that go first to
fight hand to hand in combat yeah like
you say the long range pieces they can
do their work from the first row and
whilst the players are thinking
there I would like to share with you a
meme from Craig e who says that I feel
this meme on a personal level there's me
as Hikaru blundering my queen in the
opening
we've all been there we've all done it
and there's my opponent using half his
time trying to figure out the Gambit
and this picture is a classic because I
you know lavona Ronin is playing but he
was playing our very own David Howe and
he too sacrificed was it a piece yeah
and it didn't work so I just took the
knights and I won the game and yeah I
felt guilty but uh Hikaru was just
staring down on the whole game being
like what are you doing man what are you
doing
that's true I've seen video from us
because you were commentating with Simon
I was commenting with Simon and we were
just like what is going on
and he carry also was like I don't
understand I think he kept going I don't
understand and Lavon just looked like
the most confident person ever and he
was even stretching his thing and and we
were like no we don't see it and did it
bother him to have has he said
afterwards live on he didn't say
anything about Hikaru no I'm not sure
whether he was aware Levon was still
focused on the board
um actually at some point I had to just
put my hands over my head because I
could keep seeing him I could keep
seeing so he was bothering you a little
bit Yeah and then I was trying not to
laugh so I had to go and walk around and
leave the board for a second because
hikara was just
um but at that point I was already clear
I was winning so it wasn't kind of
distracting or it wasn't gonna giving
hint or anything
um yeah that's a memorable moment oh
nice beating Livonia Ronin no incredible
games I've got to say yeah wow your
caricon your beloved character
and yeah I was very happy and it was the
final round in Gibraltar yeah I woke up
10 minutes before the game I was like oh
my God I'm late it's a 10 minute walk to
the tournament Hall from the hotel and I
was like oh what opening am I going to
play and in my head I was like okay toss
a coin basically yeah Karen Khan it
worked
it's a cone coin I mean I didn't
physically but in my head I was like
okay Eenie Meenie yeah E5 or C6 on move
one and uh luckily I chose the caracon
yeah and uh okay meanwhile Black's Night
comes into the center of the board
and uh hinting that it might jump even
further in I I'm not sure whether
there's a thread on the board maybe
there is Ivanka maybe that's yeah maybe
he's planning deep
cunning threat of actually trading off
dark squared Bishops and or maybe you're
trading off the bishop for the night
yeah exactly so for example if white
takes time out and just pushes a pawn
giving some space to the white king then
like you said Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes this Knight and the whole idea is
that okay there's a threat on this
bishop so you have to recapture and
Black's Knight would jump in with a
double attack a fork
and uh Blackwood wood material so this
Black Knight is a bit of a nuisance
having jumped in
it can't quite access this Square this
is the dream for black uh if you can
maybe trade off whites lights uh White
start Squad Bishop later on this is the
dream outpost on C3 supported and
anchored by this Pawn
but
okay how does white deal with that
threat while also trying to kick the
Knight out the first move that comes to
mind would be for example centralizing
this white Rook this was White's worst
piece you don't allow any Forks right
now you're opposite the black queen as
well but maybe my major if he's just
gonna ignore this he's gonna say okay
now I trade off your Dart Squad bishop
and once that happens for example let's
say white helps out and trades those
pieces off on Black's terms suddenly the
Knight is coming in with a fork anyway
and we might see this on the uh in the
game what's Rook did slide across and he
really cannot allow this 19 Duda if he
does it's going to be a disaster for
white again for example just to show a
fork and uh even if black wasn't winning
material this Knight is worth a whole
piece it's so strong and he's going for
the strategy
Mama Groff okay he's trying to trade off
this dark Square Bishop so the white uh
so the Black Knight has access
what do you think it's oh yeah oh wow
wow really shifting
huh is there's something wrong
tactically with this move strategically
we've explained it's very sensible very
logical we can understand why Mama jarif
went for it but uh what could be the
downside is it is it just uh um
attacking the night yeah you're right
Ivanka so white has two moves to get an
advantage anything else black has the
advantage but uh both of them moves
they're the same topic the same theme
attacking this Knight as we mentioned
you can't let it in so White's best move
actually it's very logical when you
think about it is to attack it the best
move is actually to attack with the
Bishop from this angle second best move
is to attack the knight from this angle
with the bishop both of them are similar
actually so for example if you move your
Bishop into the center he finds itself
he's a player on form isn't he he's
banging from Duda so accurate and uh
yeah he's attacking this Knight for
example Bishop takes Bishop now this
bishop would not be recaptured there's
no time you have to get rid of the Black
Knight first so you take with a knight
you take it with your bishop and uh
suddenly black has actually serious
problems too many pieces on this D file
two Bishops for example again if there's
another trade this is a deadly pin and
Blackwood loses bishop or his Queen
behind
yeah this uh really nice move there from
Duda I think my majority underestimated
this idea to be honest he was too
focused on his own plans and forgot that
white has something to say about it
yeah I can't blame him actually because
I was also following the same path that
mamajarov was thinking I was just
thinking yeah trade off the Bishops
enjoy you know enjoy active pieces and
instead there was so much danger in the
position and of course it makes sense
when you think about it the white Rook
stands opposite the black queen
tactics are always working your favor in
that scenario right
um Queens they never feel more
uncomfortable than when they're stared
down by a rook so yeah you're right
Ivanka actually the ingredients are here
for tactics to work in White's favor
also if you count the pieces that in the
game uh pretty much all the pieces are
in the game apart from Black's Rock next
to his King so black is playing without
a piece right now
and uh therefore the two white Rooks
in the center
they're making things work
wow do you think mamajaro now is aware
that he's in trouble yeah
change your body language yeah the penny
has dropped uh he knows
um it's very very much apparent you know
the head in his hands he's thinking now
and now he has to just play out of his
skin in order to save this position and
equalize now how do you pull the brakes
though how do you go solid suddenly for
black I didn't really see maybe you have
to move the Black Knight
but where to you can't allow that Knight
to be captured
from his black can jump into the
position we mentioned that C3 Square
earlier but then it will just be
captured white dark Square Bishop still
lives
um that tension on the D file again it
just looks almost decisive the more we
look at it the more or at least the more
I look at it the more I think it's just
very strong for Duda and uh mama jarov
he seems to be thinking the same he's
burning two and a half minutes now on
his clock
he had a big time advantage that's gone
yeah I mean I can't really suggest to
anything other than
the night's bringing forward and just
accepting that you're probably going to
be a pawn down
and maybe we can see the stockfish Moose
earlier we saw White had two good moves
okay black actually the advantage is
going to grow if he doesn't find the
best move here and that's to retreat the
Knight this is far from obvious oh
um actually like you said Ivanka it's
giving up a porn essentially and let's
show this on the board black has to give
up a pawn here by retreating his Knight
everything else for example treating the
dark Squad Bishops this is the second
best move but that would be great for
white uh jumping in with the Black
Knight is maybe the most natural the
third best move but why it just
eliminates this piece and for example
now would push forward it with a pawn in
the center and due to this pin the black
Bishop is lost in the center so I think
he'll rule that one out but the best
move if we go back to it is to drop back
Knight to G5 the computer says hitting
this bishop very logical but the problem
is after Bishop takes Bishop we I think
we have to recapture with the pawn
another trade hitting the black queen
you want to take with the black queen
you don't take back with a pawn ever you
shatter your Pawn structure in front of
your king too ugly so you take with the
queen and now white just went to pawn in
the center ah where it takes porn so a
little bit of calculation it's like
capture capture capture capture but
white winter point at the end and uh
they will both have worked this one out
already wow trouble for Mom there of he
is now down to four minutes oh and he's
gone forward with his Knights
looks like a peace sacrifice right yeah
because the Knight can just be capped
sorry my arrows uh the Knight could be
captured this way
and it has been captured and wants to
stop due to winning a piece now pushing
forward in the center this bishop is
pinned it can't move
yeah I'm struggling to understand maybe
there's some trick here uh to do with
how strong this black porn is but
no I don't I don't think so I didn't see
it I'm due to plays this move okay he
gives up his Queen mamajara Bishop takes
Knight he's just giving up his Queen for
the white Rook that Queen has
disappeared and uh in this position Duda
once he recaptures this bishop I think
he will immediately
um he's simply a queen for a rook up
this one is winning surely Black's
Saving Grace is at this point is really
really strong supported by Black's
Bishop but a queen for Rook it's too
much it is too much he's done it before
though he's done it before
at least in the past when Mama jarro for
sacrifice Queens normally there's an
immediate uh compensation there's an
immediate reason but
yeah he's uh he's half bluffing I think
the black Rook moves across attacking
the White Queen at least she's not great
right now she's not active and in fact
if she steps to the wrong Square she's
gonna get trapped write Ivanka if she
gets to the square she's trapped in two
different ways you can bring the black
Rook down and no Escape squares for her
yeah
so that means you have to put the queen
on the edge of the board it's only one
square so yeah one of these two squares
uh whoops yeah I would not put her in
the eye line of the dark Square Bishop
so I would step forward to the A2 yeah
this one looks a bit scary to allow the
bishop to stare down at you so uh yeah I
agree Ivanka this one looks most
sensible but suddenly the black Rooks
are coming in uh this is one attack on
the White Queen she has to step forward
I guess and maybe the other Rook could
jump in at some point okay he does go
into the corner maybe he was too scared
of the Rooks on the double uh on the
second Rank and suddenly he's playing
with fire Duda and uh okay we see the
stockfish suggestions again
still good for weight but he's fighting
this is the type of advantage that could
disappear if Black's Pawn can somehow
trick its way forward
I don't think it's safe yet you don't
want to push this Pawn because this
attack on the White Queen can maybe just
be blocked by White's Pawn
uh also maybe yeah I mean I guess you
should step for the pawn forward and
next move this guy drops off so keep
that pawn on the board and the computer
says in this position you want to stop
this idea of pushing forward by blocking
it with your Bishop just block this Pawn
the bishop actually controls a lot of
squares that's not obvious I've got to
say it feels like a position you
sacrificed your queen
you've got to play Fast you've got to
find something immediate but the
computer says just play Slowly it's fine
you're a queen down the game goes on but
uh wow the second best move also a quiet
one I guess it's just to move the Rook
across and go for this
this isolated Pawn so both players are
now just staring at this black pawn
yeah that's the center of their Focus
right now for mandaro to keep it on the
board and for do that to get it off the
board yeah dude would love to even
sacrifice a rook uh in order to get rid
of it later on uh as long as he can get
maybe let's give both sides a couple of
moves just to show an example but uh if
say he gets the opportunity maybe not
here but Rook takes Pawn this would be
the dream getting rid of the pawn and
Black's Bishop for the rook and white
would emerge with an extra Bishop so
okay this was prevented but this is not
a recommended move uh by the computer
blacks Rook came in to me it's the most
natural actually uh bringing the black
rook in but what's the downside to this
one
uh the black Rook looks nice and active
maybe there's just no threat
what can white do now computer goes to
plus four wow I don't understand this
because to me it looks it can't be a bad
move you know black is threatening to
push the C Pawn one square forward and
goodness me that's terrifying and uh oh
wow he pushes forward due to giving away
a pawn
free seemingly uh the pawn is gobbled up
what is the idea I guess he's freed up
the bishop on this nice long diagonal
but
I didn't see the plan is is he going to
also push his C Pawn say you've got a
passport I want one too
yeah a battle of the sea Pawns it's
weird to have pause this way around
normally Black's Pawn would be blocking
the white porn neither Pawn is blocking
the other here or maybe he just wants to
uh you free up his Bishop defensively
yeah I think he just wanted to free up
this piece like you said to Ivanka now
he has access to this diagonal at least
uh but the computer did not like it it
didn't approve of giving up a pawn for
free still a queen for Rook Advantage
but uh the White Queen is pretty bad
right now
I mean I would be terrified I've got to
say of the white King on the back rank I
would want to step forward a pawn at
some point I'm not sure whether I have
time but just want to give it some
breathing space and Escape Square
I'm not sure whether that's a good move
uh like you said to your backup maybe
this one pushing forward sure should we
have a loco if you can take a breather
if you push the pawn
I mean is the black porn also going to
advance I mean because this position
looks so dangerous despite the bar being
all the way on white side I mean this is
just not how it works when chess is paid
out amongst humans yeah
if it's computer versus computer you're
right it's just a win for white
essentially but human versus human you
get scared of this Pawn uh stepping
forward you get scared of it promoting
maybe you accidentally get your king
trapped on the back rank
actually the more I look at it the more
I think Shaq is just I mean we knew this
already he's a genius but he's found a
really nice practical way to continue it
was either this or suffer right in uh
suffer a pulling down position with no
chance of winning this one
he's either losing or he might turn it
around and win I agree this is the way
to defend against those unpleasant
positions you've got to create uh Messer
you've got to be that agent of Chaos and
I like what he's doing and when it comes
to the clock times well yeah just to do
the just under three minutes I spent
nearly half his time on this one move
and understandably that might be the
worst Queen I've ever seen I've got to
say so what what is a queen for Rook up
and all queens are good pieces but
what's Queen what is it doing in the
corner blocked in by blacks Rook that's
true so that is the compensation that's
why it's tricky for white if you could
pick up the queen and put her on an
active Square then
probably just game over but okay he is
activating that piece
and uh now again the question you think
can that black porn uh push can it
continue as much now it's much more
tempting especially because the white
king doesn't have a Heidi hole to escape
to evaluation bar dropping every move
now this is how difficult it is to
handle for white
and you said this Pawn push is tempting
what else could black consider here
um maybe you can move the black Bishop I
mean this moves to the first move you
want to play right uh push this Pawn
and as you mentioned if white does does
now make space then suddenly the black
root comes forward it's pinning it's
about to remove the defender uh the
blockader this white Rook maybe this is
winning for black suddenly because for
example if you step your king forward
the black Bishop comes in oh it's still
tricky there's still some tactics here
but uh if you can remove this blockader
you make a new Queen with your Pawn
I mean this is the this is the ambitious
way right the acid test of what white is
doing critical idea but does it work if
you if you can't make it work if you're
too nervous maybe you bring your Bishop
forward and try to go for this Pawn
I don't think black has time to make a
space for his King himself he would love
to I was I was going to ask that because
uh
if black is vulnerable on the back rank
as well the black king is trapped behind
his own pawns and uh you have to
remember yes the queen is a badly placed
for the time being but she can swoop in
uh especially to the E7 square and just
make a real nuisance of herself so still
white has their defensive resources yeah
I mean still anyone's game who would you
pick here Ivanka if you didn't see the
evaluation bar
oh
that's such a tough question I probably
would choose the queen but I I would
make sure I spent so much time on every
move you know just checking and
rechecking all my variations because the
margin of error here
so small you make a mistake you're going
to pay with it with your life yeah
I guess the reason we would choose the
queen is that at least worse comes to
worst that black porn runs through you
give up your Rook for it and you'll get
a situation where it's what queen versus
two Rooks
roughly balanced maybe you're slightly
better than the two Rooks but uh that's
like worst case scenario if you're black
worst case scenario is your Pawn drops
off and you're just a queen down so much
of error tiny like you said Ivanka but
maybe the margin is smaller for black
I'm a jar of under one minute we said
they were quick players
um is there any only 27 moves okay he
does take a time out to create Luft uh
create air for the black king this
probably allows the white king to also
do the same you know because if you feel
then his nervousness there with no way
to escape to
copy yeah copycat absolutely push your
Pawn in front of the white king just
like black did there
I'm not sure who it benefits more but uh
benefits both just not sure who it
benefits more yeah
wow what a game
so many surprises we barely predicted
that middle bit where black gave up a
piece and gave up a queen but you know
the action happened very early on and uh
you know it's still critical around move
27. you're right Ivanka you've said it
yesterday between move 20 and 40 that's
where the action happens between these
two I mean you see some Grand Masters
where the action really happens like
move 50 60 into the end game you see
somewhere it happens only 10 but moved
between move 10 and 20. here it's middle
game yeah both of them are so creative
and dude are tanking now on the clock
well he doesn't have too much time on
his clock either he's ticking down to
just over a minute and the heat is on
for both of these players it's another
roller coaster game it has to go to
start to the final day obviously
muhammadorov he is fighting for a
comeback it's not looking good for him
right now and if he loses this game it's
getting really dramatic then he will
have to win two games
and only three rapid games to go
I mean I definitely I see the bar so I
understand it's most likely that Duda
will win this game but all scenario is
still possible definitely as long as
that black porn exists as long as it
lives and uh like Ivanka said just one
slip and we'll see the bar swing the
whole way to Black side and dude was
frustrated okay he does eventually copy
black creating some air for the white
king but that's the one risk is what
look at this the evaluation bar now on
black side yeah
and uh well this is the type of position
where anything can happen I mean such a
natural move I mean really why is why
does it the bar not like it there must
be something concrete for black maybe
it's bringing in this second Rook uh
again that's what we call the blind pigs
they'll just eat anything in their path
uh on that second rank the white pawns
are just doomed they're gonna drop off
but the question for Duda is can he
eliminate this Pawn we said this was the
key I don't think black should get
greedy now and capture this white Rook I
think
I think white sorry black can force a
draw here by attacking the queen
the White Queen yeah you keep very
clever yeah let's show this on the board
it's getting really tense manager of
under 20 seconds and uh you can attack
the White Queen you don't want to take
this Rook first if you take this Rook
you lose your bishop and black Bishop is
the key here a queen and Bishop together
will beat two Rooks essentially you're a
piece up a queen is the same as two
Rooks white has a bishop for free and he
goes for your idea of anchor uh he
doesn't take this Rook he wants to kick
away the protection of this Rook first
so The Rook bullies the queen If It
Moves uh if it moves to this Square
actually then you can move across this
way and she's almost trapped she has to
go the whole way back and then the Rook
drops next to her wow things are turning
in Black's favor dude it goes the other
way he steps one square forward
and Black's Bishop comes in it's Mama
jar of gonna Checkmate Duda whoa yeah
it's looking that way David yeah
suddenly the white King has been
abandoned White's Queen and Rook are too
far away and the F2 point is always the
weakest in White's camp
in any chess position especially here
it's gonna get captured black is going
to be attacking with a bishop and with
two Rooks
suddenly how does white even do anything
White's Queen can't even counter-attack
there's one check but look how safe
Black's King is no more checks ever
Black's King is super safe okay he
pushes a pawn forward but suddenly
something is about to drop on this
Square
oh it looks okay black is winning wow
you take it with a bishop this is
winning because if the king steps
forward the bishop drops back with the
Discover check winning the queen at the
same time let's go back to the players
is gonna take this game
what a turnaround he just needs to give
another check
due to Smiling he was a queen up
and he's lost it
and we'll see this uh okay White's other
Rook has gone and next move wherever the
King goes Black's Rook is going to jump
out the way with the check Black's
Bishop will capture the White Queen game
over oh